hi there steve kaufman here today to do
a video in response to the wonderful
video that benny the irish polyglot and
his friendly polyglots
put together
to congratulate me on 10 years on
youtube i will put a link to the video
up in the description box i've even got
my jacket and tie on here because benny
has a bow tie in his and i feel i have
to be a little formal in my response
although
i have my
golf shorts on because i'm going golfing
thank you very much i'm blown away by
the video
and i always like to take a lesson from
things that happen and somehow relate
them to language learning
so there are two things that sort of
come out sort of strike me in this video
first of all
is the sheer effort that went into
putting the video together effort with
creativity
cooperation
uh and it's something that i admire in
benny
and that is you know he has an attitude
which is just do it
whether it be just speak the language
from day one or in the case of putting a
video like this together it's a lot of
work
you can think it up that's one thing but
to actually go ahead and do it and make
it happen that's another thing
and all of the people who participated
in this video not only did they
put a lot of thought and and probably
several trial runs into
their participation but these are also
people like benny who have put the
effort into learning other languages
many languages
and again it's not as some people like
to say oh well you have a talent for
languages it's because these people
decided to just do it
i think that's a nike slogan or
something i hope i don't get into
trouble for using it
but
any of you out there who's ever thought
of learning a language it starts by
just doing it
the second point that i want to make is
that the people who are on that video
all of whom i have met except for i
think michael campbell
uh
their
representative
of the polyglot community people that i
met in montreal
last year
in bratislava recently that i'm going to
meet again in montreal on the 25th of
august
these are the
friendliest
supportive most mutually encouraging
group of people i have come across
and i have been in diplomatic circles as
business circles and these are the best
people
and
anyone of you who has not been to a
polyglot conference or who hasn't dipped
your toe in language learning i suggest
you get going you will never regret it
and each language every language has its
own reasons for being worthwhile
learning
and i'm going to try
with my uh you know i have been away
from some of these languages for a while
i'm going to try to
comment
uh to each of the participants in the
language that they used
and i will even just do it commit to
providing subtitles which because i'm
sometimes lazy i don't always do when i
make videos in other languages all right
it starts with benny and of course he
begins by speaking english so i'm
speaking english and i've already
mentioned benny but i'll get back to
benny in different languages
then we had lindsay
a persona enthusiast
that was lindsay
then if i remember correctly
uh
benny came back in sign language i can't
do sign language i can just do hi benny
that's about all i can do uh in sign
language i i'm not sure i'll ever learn
sign language but i respect you for
having learned it
then i think we had
chris speaking dean yes naka dance yeah
however they say in danish
and chris is a great guy
and uh very warm person
and uh i thank him for apparently
inspiring this video by discovering the
fact that i had some kind of an old
chair that i bought in a in um
i guess it was a garage sale or
something i can't even remember
uh or a secondhand store
then we had ollie
yeah at night in swedish
thank him very much for his kind words
then we
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
so that was uh connor in ukrainian and
then we had
uh
jan speaking dutch i'm not even gonna
attempt dutch
jan is a great guy i met him in on
several of these occasions look forward
hopefully you're seeing them in montreal
i'm not going to attempt dutch but i may
learn dutch one day
social
um
that was in mandarin for
um
mike campbell
then we had
a benny italiano
uh what else did we have uh lydia and
petro you know i had a great time in
slovakia uh malson
velmi er nadhernay
thank you for everything you did
for the bratislava
polyglide gathering
and then we had we have azo kirsten
of
of
[Music]
unfortunately i don't speak esperanto
however
i
let us say i do recognize that esperanto
is a wonderful language to learn as a
means of encouraging students
to learn languages because it's easier
to learn apparently and therefore once
people achieve success in learning one
language esperanto that may very well
encourage them to learn other languages
so
there you have it my response but beyond
anything else i want to thank the people
who put this together
uh i
very much appreciate it and i look
forward to seeing most of you in
montreal august 25th to 27th thank you
very much i hope i didn't forget anyone
or didn't forget any language bye for
now
je vais
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you